الحرب في اوكرانيا كشفت اهميه الاقمار
الصناعيه في الفضاء اكثر من اي وقت مضى
بعدما ارتفعت نسبه استخدام الفضاء ومعدات
المراقبه والانترنت لاغراض عسكريه فهل
يكون الفضاء مسرحا لحرب عالميه ثالثه بدلا
من الارض يحذر هنا موقع نيوزرو الرسل
بعدما كشف بان البنتاغون بدا يجهز قاعده
استخباراتيه لحرب النجوم المستقبليه عبر
طبعا اطلاق مجموعه من الاقمار الصناعيه
تحت اسم ما يعرف بسايلنت باركر الى الفضاء
هذا الصيف بما سيسمح طبعا لهم بمراقبه
تحركات كل من روسيا والصين وهذا الامر
اكدته هنا الاكاديميه الروسيه للملاحه
الفضائيه اعتبرت بان اطلاق مجموعه ما يعرف
بسايلنت باركور اي المرحله التاليه في
عسكره الفضاء يعتبر مرحله تاليه في هذه
العسكره بالنسبه للولايات المتحده لان
البنتاغون قلق من الصين نظرا لامتلاكها
اسلحه مصممه للتدبير الاقمار الصناعيه
وعلى وجه الخصوص الجهاز الصيني
الذي اطلق عام 2021 ونجح طبعا لاحقا في
رفع قمر صناعي صيني الى مدار اعلى سيشكل
مشاهدينا ما يعرف
الصيني ووجود وجود طبعا بالفضاء خطرا على
الاقمار الصناعيه الامريكيه ثابته ويعرض
هذه الاقمار للتدمير وفق ما قالته هنا
قياده الفضاء الامريكيه اما روسيا
فستستطيع هي الاخرى اسقاط او تدمير
الاقمار الصناعيه في حاله حدوث تصادم او
في حاله توجيه مقذوفات حركيه صغيره الحجم
نحو هذه النجوم كما ان موسكو قادره على
اسقاط الاقمار الصناعيه في مدارات منخفضه
بواسطه طائرات مقاتله على ارتفاعات عاليه
طبعا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات